One of the central
tasks of this course
has been to unpack the ways in
which work in today's economy
has changed over time.
Often, when we talk
about this topic,
one of the first things
that comes to mind
is the role of technology
in transforming work.
Over the past few years, we
have seen an explosion in what's
known as the on-demand economy.
It's visible everywhere.
We as consumers are able
to have our food delivered,
grab a ride home, or even have
someone run their errands,
all purchased and arranged
in a matter of minutes
from our smartphones.
Our colleague John
McCarthy talks
in more detail
about these new ways
of organizing work
in a different video
lecture in this course.
What we're going
to talk about now
is how these
employment arrangements
are connected to two issues--
one, how we think
about workers' rights
in the on-demand economy, and
two, how technology can promote
new forms of worker advocacy
in settings where gigs,
not full-time jobs
for one employer,
are becoming the
employment norm.
Many consumers and
workers alike find
the flexibility and efficiency
of the on-demand economy
to be beneficial.
Work hours are
flexible, for instance,
and the efficiency of
services saves people time.
As has been pointed out,
however, many workers
undertaking the actual
jobs of these companies
are employed as
independent contractors,
meaning that they are not direct
employees of the company that
is bringing us the
good or the service.
A babysitter who gets his work
through the website Care.com,
for instance, is considered
to be self-employed.
This means that the benefits and
protections that we associate
with full time, stable jobs,
such as access to paid leave
or unemployment
insurance, are not
available to on-demand workers.
Likewise, standards that
promote good, quality jobs
are often absent from
these arrangements,
as we've seen through
the recent protests
by Uber drivers over
wages and terms of work
in various cities.
So the traditional system
of benefits and protections
based on full time jobs
and employment status
no longer makes sense
in these settings.
Innovative, disruptive
technologies
that change the way business
is done and work is performed
require simultaneous
innovative changes
in how workers are able to
access rights on the job.
What we've talked
about in this course
is updating the social
contract at work.
One approach to such
change comes with support
from a broad coalition of
technology firms, labor
organizations, academics,
and foundations.
The idea is pretty simple--
that benefits and
protections should
accrue with the work
being performed,
no matter the employer.
In other words, the number
of sick days, for instance,
a gig worker can accrue should
depend on the number of hours
she works, whether providing
rides or delivering groceries.
Although firms would
contribute to these benefits
and protections, they
would essentially
remain with the worker,
allowing for economic security
even when working for
multiple employers.
They can be structured in a way
that promotes good jobs that
pay living wages.
And by making these
portable benefits universal,
they can also extend to workers
beyond the on-demand economy,
helping ease the now-commonplace
transitions that many of us
experience moving from
one employer to the next.
The idea of portable
benefits mimics
these new on-demand
arrangements that
characterize growing
portions of the economy.
Likewise, advocates are
also finding new ways
to use technology to promote
workers' rights on the job.
In some cases, this is directly
relevant to on-demand workers
themselves.
Relatively new websites, such
as coworker.org and Dynamo,
serve as online
hubs where workers
can start petitions for
change, rate their experience
with certain
employers, and connect
with others in their industry.
Turkopticon is a
similar application
that allows crowd workers
on Amazon's Mechanical Turk
to rate employers.
These applications
compliment organizing efforts
in other settings as well.
In our last video, we
talked about Our Walmart,
an organization of
non-unionized Walmart workers
advocating for better
working conditions.
Using an online campaign
through coworker.org,
Our Walmart was recently able
to gather widespread support
for their demands regarding
more stable hours.
In response, Walmart changed
the way they schedule shifts.
With support from an
innovative organization
called the Workers Lab, which
promotes new forms of worker
organizing, Our Walmart
is also developing
an app that allows workers to
connect with one another while
receiving peer-generated
advice and training
relevant to their jobs.
Other organizations are
developing applications
that not only serve to
connect workers and mobilize
around specific demands, but
also to inform and educate
workers about their
rights on the job.
The Domestic Worker
app, for example,
was created in response to the
passage of a domestic worker
bill of rights in
New York state.
Caregivers, nannies, and
cleaners can call in or text
to access both recorded and
live informational episodes
and messages about their
rights under the state's
new legislation.
A different approach is taken
by the Restaurant Opportunity
Center, the organization
of restaurant workers
we discussed in our last video.
The center's Top
Server app is a game
that teaches its users
about the skills needed
to advance in restaurants,
imparting training, knowledge,
and even the lingo
used in restaurant work
to servers looking for ways
to advance in the industry.
To be clear, these
new forms of advocacy
are not a replacement for
direct work or organizing
and other advocacy work.
But as these organizations
show, the types
of technologies that are
transforming the way we work
can also be used to
strengthen our efforts
to create good jobs.
And as the on-demand
economy continues
to be fueled by growing
consumer demand,
we will continue to be
presented with opportunities
for a potential innovation
and re-establishing
the social contract at work,
not just for on-demand workers,
but for all workers
throughout the economy.